when it just uh didn't work out he
definitely tried especially with his
opening choice in the early middle game
he had some pressure but magnus
he's the world champion for a reason he
knows how to defend these difficult
positions and he just locked things down
he kind of curled up into a ball rock
solid and there was no way through not
much else to be said it was just a solid
play by both sides
well we're gonna jump into game two
between eric hansen and andre sipenko
the first game ended in a draw they are
tied eric here with the white pieces and
is his image frozen or is he in extreme
deep thought
i think that's just a picture
is that what it is
why either that or he might be dead like
someone no he looks like a jedi master
yeah very impressive well it's a nice
picture then uh instructive and what's
happening in this game 21 moves into it
yeah the position is still relatively
balanced just doing a quick count of
material it's level material level pawns
level pieces but the theme of the day is
isolated pawns isolated queens pawns if
you look in the center of the board
black's pawn in the middle there has no
support by other pawns so that pawn a
long term target as we mentioned in the
other game
but in return black does have the bishop
power so actually a lot of similarities
to the game we just came from uh just
with colours reversed this time black is
the one with the isolated pawn i mean
i'm very optimistic when i'm attacking
uh and maybe over optimistic but i have
to say i mean i'm quite surprised by the
computer's assessment because these
knights that white has hovering around
the black king and the queen just count
how many pieces white has he has the
queen the two knights maybe a rook and
bishop it looks really scary uh for
espnko here there's always a sacrifice
you have to watch out for um i'd be
feeling extremely optimistic if if i was
white here so i think i think this is a
possibility for eric here i mean he's
got a a decent attacking position and
he's got this isolated pawn uh in the
ending in some cases so i i prefer white
uh just looking at it
yeah um i agree i slightly prefer white
as well um this game okay now we've just
seen some trades bishops coming off
rooks coming off but this game
originated from the italian opening and
i've analyzed this exact variation and i
was always surprised as well simon
white's position always looks so nice so
pleasant but the computer always says
0.0 or 0.1 and it's so frustrating um so
yeah maybe we ignore the evaluation bar
for now and just look for ideas on the
board that's what the players will be
doing and uh are you surprised by this
rook trade yeah i'm very surprised
because uh uh
what's the what's the continuation
what's the point of this rick trade i
mean i like quite like the tension
before that the two rooks had here i
mean i'm just guessing that queen takes
is there is there going to be something
terrible happening after queen takes
rook did he have to play it because
maybe one of one of the only issues i
can see for white is uh the the arry
pawns if you can move the both the a
pawns back to their starting squares i
think white's advantage should be a lot
greater but having this pawn on the
left-hand side of the board um is
attacked by black's bishop so your rook
is kind of a little bit tied down to
defending that one and uh i think that's
that's that's one well one of the only
advantages i can see espionco has has
here and maybe that's why he kept the
did this exchange possibly maybe also
you know i completely forgot about the
left side of the board i had to say i
was just so focused on the right but i
was thinking maybe the black queen can
actually get involved in the defense as
well
just plant herself on the f6 square and
then
happy days right queen is a good
defender yeah yeah although maybe this
pawn would be hanging uh so okay we do
see a trade of rocks meanwhile uh
black's queen has captured in the center
white's knight stepping back actually
this pawn was up for grabs on the side
of the board defended by the black queen
but then white would capture and
i think maybe this would slightly favor
white because there is some uh there are
some threats so instead black jumping
forward with the knight
in this position hitting the white queen
and look how esopenko has centralized
his queen uh very very nice a moment ago
simon you were saying oh the two white
knights are jumping forward maybe
attacking the white queen was an
attacking piece now black black is the
one with a better knight yeah
it does strike me if you put the pawn on
a4 let's say back on a2
you could even go for a queen exchange
here and you'd have the ideal isolated
pawn position but just having this one
pawn out the board and these are the
very small details that that make all
the difference at this level is is a
major major issue for white in in in the
endings that pawn is attacked by the
bishop you can't move your rook your
rook is tied down and uh maybe even
saves espnko from a very difficult
defensive job here
yeah i do like this last move though
from eric hanson dropping his knight
back black's knight was just too strong
and uh if we do see a trade here then as
you mentioned simon maybe the queens
will come off the board for example and
this position would be very very
pleasant for white except this pawn
being a target
meaning the white rook can't move so uh
yeah right now it looks very balanced
and we might be headed towards an end
game such as this one where both sides
will rush to get their king centralized
and
most likely we'll reach a situation
where neither side can make too much
progress um okay the queens are about to
come off the board most likely i don't
think black should really try and keep
the queens on because queen and knight
work better as a combo than a queen and
bishop for example if the black queen
steps back this knight is now just
unchallenged and white's queen if it can
somehow combine with the knight towards
the black king later might cause some
nuisance then again this is probably
fine as well
i i would just take the queens off
centralize the black king though and uh
esopenko as well great endgame player as
we saw when he beat magnus carson in the
prelims both players down to ish four
minutes on the clock eric hanson is a
fantastic speed player right and and
especially on online chess how is
andreas panko when it comes to these
super fast time controls she's good but
maybe not as experienced as eric in
blitz and bullet time formats uh so i
think eric would be very happy if this
match went into tie breaks
um esopenko actually played him at blitz
recently just a few months ago and i won
we had a two game match i won the first
one i was two moves away from
checkmating when the second one i lost
on time so
he's good but i think eric maybe you did
beat sap encode let's in the last time
you play in the classical game yeah
we've got to get the shout out there
yeah thank you you nearly qualified for
the candidates you know that was don't
put yourself down you weren't we were
all cheering you on weren't we like come
on dave world champion how well talk
about david in in over-the-board chess
something very cool is coming up and how
long is it is it like a week one week
exactly yeah yeah yeah we'll be playing
a match against the swedish number one
niels grandelias we're actually playing
at the swedish embassy in london which
is uh pretty cool then simon next to me
i think he might be commenting on some
of the games yeah yeah we've asked yeah
look really much yeah i look so much
forward to that and it's going to be a
long match as well
ten game wow it's basically like the
world championship match just with
slightly lower rate of players so
it's oh it's going to be so intense 10
game match
and it all starts in one week and of
course you can follow all that action on
chess 24 when it starts we're oh it's
going to be thrilling it is yeah england
against sweden yes how they're marketing
it
so david i just need not that much
pressure
oh i haven't studied enough lately
but uh we'll see i'll try my best ah
yeah that's going to be very very cool i
can recommend some chess ball courses
for you if you'd like yes please yeah no
you know there's the harry attack i hear
that's a really good chess ball course
that's just come out so uh you're
telling me of my preparation now anybody
won't be watching worry
great to see you play over the board as
well so thank you and uh meanwhile the
position has changed slightly the queens
have come off the board and
white has solidified so white's pawn
structure on the left side it looks a
bit loose but it's all defended for now
and black struck on a bit of an awkward
square defending the pawn next to it
that isolated pawn in the middle of the
board and i mean talking of me playing
over the board chess again i think i
pick white i've had this type of
position plenty of times throughout my
career from those openings we mentioned
simon yeah uh earlier but about you
vanco i mean this is i think i'd pick
whites as well um it looks like white
could move the king in as you say and
you know the bishop looks pretty bad but
i i would pick white as well but then
i'm an internal optimist so i wouldn't
be like massively unhappy if i will with
by playing black pieces
yeah yeah it's probably should be a draw
but there's a lot of play left here yeah
and the times ticking down as well i
mean they're both under four minutes
which is uh
gonna going to bring more tension do you
think one of them is more nervous eric
mentioned he was very nervous yesterday
understandably he doesn't really show
his emotion espienko on the other hand
but he's moving a lot more than eric at
the moment eric's like a statue there
caught eric but he he's very he moves
about a lot doesn't he uh we're talking
about players like habits sometimes that
can put you off and
one of my pers well i've got many
personal hates bitter old man i am is
is having an opponent who bounces about
when you're playing them um it can be
quite off-putting but okay it doesn't
matter for this match of course
both sides bring their kings in not much
changing at the moment no and one
question i always ask myself in these
types of positions is who would uh
profit from a rook exchange for example
if pieces do come off the board and here
i think if rooks come off the board it's
just gonna be a dead draw
i don't think white has it may be
slightly favors work but i don't think
white has enough material left or enough
weaknesses to probe at uh meanwhile
esopenko trying to initiate some
exchanges maybe trying to activate the
black bishop there we go black
recaptures white's knight parks itself
in the center now so black cannot go and
grab a pawn because it's forced to stay
defending its bishop the bishop has to
move
and white now will defend his c pawn
that is attacked by the black rook
there we go white's rook stepping across
maybe slightly favoring white this
exchange because black does have two
isolated pawns now white has no isolated
pawns our friend keith arkle
the english grand master
you mentioned it yesterday porn islands
he prefers having as few as possible
then again
yeah yeah i think with that exchange
there it is certainly well more
exchanges more nearer draw both sides
are getting here uh i mean the white
knight is still slightly better um so
i'd take white here if i had to take one
side without a shadow of a doubt if
white can activate his rook then you
know there's play here
yeah going for it but i mean i do think
that black has a very good defensive
square for the bishop and you can see
it's been played but uh eric is doing
all the right
moves because you hear he defends his uh
pawn from the side and that just means
that his rook is still active still in
the game still lots to play for actually
yeah yep and i'm slightly surprised he
defended it with his rook like this i
don't understand why he didn't bring his
king in to defend that pawn first and
then fully activate the white rook i
think it would have saved a move in the
process but maybe more exchanges maybe
uh black's gonna push that pawn to
challenge white's pawn that's just moved
and i mean they're they're gonna get
exchanged off aren't they i feel here
you see harry the h4 moving up the board
simon you just want to get it off you
want to trade it it's too scary far too
dangerous at porn and there we go there
we go it happens a potential trade yeah
and yeah pawns are disappearing
everything's disappearing this one
is heading towards the draw yeah the
white king is centralizing that's always
good news yeah again you'd still rather
be white um totally slightly slightly
yeah definitely
um i one thing i'm finding really
impressive by all the players even
though they're getting these equal
positions they're playing them on uh
they're not agreeing a draw which i
really like the fighting spirit they're
showing i think a lot of people would
save energy you know in other
tournaments and degree draw but they're
playing it out which is great for us to
see um and yeah i mean it probably will
be a draw but you can you can fight
yeah
i i mean i think we're going to see them
fight it out for a long time despite the
fact
it is the most likely result now and
actually when eric first burst onto the
scene uh what was it over 10 years ago i
remember seeing a lot of his games and
i think he tries to kind of style
himself as a really aggressive player
but most of his best wins were in these
kind of technical end games
because he would just get in the flow
just put a bit of pressure on i think
sometimes his nerves do affect him so in
this position there's no risk at all
which helps with nerves and
i think if he was maybe playing a lower
rated player he would be very confident
that he could press this one home with
white do you know who eric's uh in an
interview i saw his favorite player
of all time is or one of his players but
he said you know who do you really
appreciate i think he mentioned his
favorite player i mean could you guess
um
not karpov no
ivanka
um
kasparov no it was actually england's
own vicky adams wow yeah she said he
really appreciated uh england you know
england top player mickey adams who's uh
who plays uh like a spider he controls
the board and he creeps around and spins
his weather the spins is where brilliant
uh positional player
and eric uh you can see that in this
kind of game that's quite a playing you
know he is known as an aggressive player
but actually his favorite player is a
very positional player and very well
founded so uh yeah and he's now trying
to get his king into the middle right i
mean this is like that move that you
kind of mentioned that's a real
spider-like move you know you're
controlling the rook and like you say
stepping the king into the middle um i
know the computer says it's like dead on
equal but this is scary stuff for black
yeah i mean if i was black i'd try to
activate my rook i mean just bring it
around the back if i can we talked about
the ending and um one of the most
important things you've got to do in a
rook ending is just bring your work to
the most active
place you can and i would bring it all
the way into the corner all the way into
another corner and then along i mean
something like that is uh is a way that
i i try to play this there you go
there's those
coming into the corner there and just
got to keep your pieces active
in in the ending and i think this holds
the balance just about here yeah so it's
not heating up
quite
eric's trying to make it heat up but uh
ice cold just uh finding all these nice
defensive
cool very instructive defense by uh kind
of lukewarm at the moment yeah i guess
so i think it's pretty exciting actually
because i think it's quite instructive
what both players are doing you know how
white is slowly trying to nudge forward
and black does not sit passively and
it's gonna go start attacking those
pawns there on the right and the reason
this is
probably quite a straightforward draw is
just because black only has one weakness
there is a theory in chess that you need
two weaknesses in your opponent's camp
to attack you need one to deflect your
opponent's forces and then you need to
break through against one weakness and
here if you look at black's central
point it's isolated that's the only
weakness but it is defended by black's
bishop and
it's just not enough for white and also
white does have to be careful as uh
ivanka mentioned of what black's rook
now entering and attacking some pawns as
well so white locks down his own pawns
putting them on light squares
same color as the opponent's bishop a
bit risky maybe but uh yeah that just
shows that eric i think just wants to
lock down this position
and uh yeah it's a draw is still
imminent most likely this is uh game two
between eric hanson and andreas penko in
their quarterfinal match uh jana
pomnyacci and vincent kymer they have
started game three
they are tied after two games magnus
carlsen and liam led just started game
three magnus carlsen is up by one point
and if he wins this game with the white
pieces he will already be ready for the
semi-finals we will jump right into that
game as soon as this one finishes
and
yeah i guess it's going to be a draw
shortly or will they keep fighting i
think quite shortly now because black's
done everything right look how active
black's rook has suddenly become also
pinning important against the white king
look how active the black king is as
well i think now as white the time has
come to just
uh just force a draw just by for example
starting with a check from the white
knight forcing the black king back
retreating and then i think we'll see a
repetition of the position uh there we
go a night check forcing the black king
back and
the draw is coming any moment now this
is the second time we've seen this
position if we see this position once
more it's a draw instantly okay and uh
nothing else to do with white black is
just too active now
will eric be happy with this he is
obviously the lowest ranked player in
this quarter final match tied after two
games
i think so remember the blitz is one of
his home territories and if we get to
blitz i think it's almost 50 50. so
um yeah now two games down two games to
go
eric can't be unhappy so i see panko
maybe starting to stress a little bit
when they go into game three and he will
have the white pieces
i think he's got a push in the next game
because it's uh his last white um before
uh the blitz so he maybe has to take a
bit more risks than he would do normally
eric's putting a great performance in
though
and even here he's thinking can i get
any blood out of this stone uh you can
take the draw straight away but he he's
he's still thinking like i want to fight
which
which is showing the right attitude at
least as long as he doesn't think for
another two minutes like that then that
would be the wrong attitude yeah um the
famous chess bra why why chess bra
brothers right
it's like flank bra my bra yes like the
canadian version of bro
i thought it was actually doing brass
when it first
you were expecting some female chess
players when you chose them to the chess
brother yeah
i realized it's like yeah it's like bro
isn't it yeah
chess bro
so yeah all right well our chess bro is
uh thinking and he is thinking about um
going into this draw basically repeating
the position or to keep fighting is this
sensible to just take a minute think
about it i mean he's spending his time
now so
basically it's getting more and more
relevant to take that draw i guess
definitely i think the risk involved
with playing on now is just unreasonable
for white uh if you step back with the
white king for example then the black
king will come in at some point and okay
we are about to see the draw black's
king is going to step back and that's
the third time we've seen that position
it's game over it is a draw and we move
on to game three yeah